-Our next guest is an
Academy Award and Grammy winner,
a Rock & Roll Hall of Fame
inductee,
and former front man
of Talking Heads.
His Tony Award-winning
Broadway show,
"American Utopia," is
running through April
at the St. James Theatre.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend David Byrne.
Hello, David. How are you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, Seth. Hi, Seth.
Great to be back.
-It's great to have you back.
A surreal time to be doing
a Broadway show
these last two years,
especially these last few weeks.
I know that you had an outbreak
at the show.
You did not have to cancel it,
though.
You did sort of
a modified performance.
How did that come about?
-Wow, yes, yes.
Like a lot of shows, we had,
like, a couple of people
who tested positive
and had to go out,
and they were covered
by understudies.
And then more,
and then more, and then more.
until half the cast,
half the band was out,
and some of the crew, as well,
and we couldn't do the show
anymore.
And some of us talked
amongst ourselves
and said, "Well, maybe we can do
a kind of unplugged
kind of thing.
We'll do some other songs,
some, you know, catalog songs,
other, you know, Talking Heads
songs, whatever,
and just kind of see if the
audience wants to hear that.
We won't be doing
any of the choreography,
we won't be doing this show,
but we'll give them something.
So, if they come
from out of town,
as people did over the holidays,
we'll have something for them."
And they can -- as I said
in this little message --
I said, "You can either
get your money back
or you can take
what's behind the curtain."
[ Laughter ]
-I would imagine people
found that exciting,
to be able to go to a show
and get something more unique
than what the normal show was.
-Yeah, I think
audiences really liked it.
It was not slick and perfect.
There were times when I had to
stop and ask the band,
"Who starts this song?"
[ Laughter ]
And the audience loved that.
They would, like,
applaud for stuff like that.
-Your show, which I saw
before the pandemic
and loved a great deal,
it's very optimistic.
it also has
a lot of audience engagement.
You ask them
to get up and dance.
Are people still
engaged with the show?
Are people still happy
to get up and dance
when you demand it of them?
-They are getting up and dancing
even to this kind of unplugged
version that we're doing.
So, yeah, says something
about audiences
that they really
want to be together.
They really want to kind of
express themselves
and dance and have a good time.
And a shout-out to Gustavo
over there on the bandstand.
-Yes, we're very happy.
Thank you so much.
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you for
lending us your drummer.
One of the -- You know,
the show looks beautiful,
and one of the things about it
is, the, you know -- the
wardrobe is gray suits.
Also, you're barefoot.
How did you come up with that
decision of those two elements
of how the show would look?
-Uh, little by little.
It was very practical.
I thought suits would kind of
make everyone look
sort of attractive
and kind of, well,
almost like one size fits all.
You can kind of -- everybody can
look good, decent in a suit,
women and men.
And then I -- And just asked
the lighting director.
I said, "What color
do you want them?"
And they said, "Medium gray."
immediately, medium gray.
-[ Laughs ]
-I thought, "Okay."
That was so that when we --
if they put light on us,
we can be seen;
and if they take the light away,
we can disappear.
if we go kind of
upstage into the darkness,
we'll disappear.
If we were wearing a white suit,
which I love to wear sometimes,
it would be really hard
to have me kind of disappear.
So it's purely practical.
[ Chuckles ]
-And the bare feet?
Um, the bare feet --
I mean, once you're
in a business suit,
I thought, "We're not gonna wear
business shoes.
That's going a little too far."
-Yeah.
You know, you're still
a rock 'n' roller.
You can't be wearing
a suit and shoes.
-[ Laughing ] Yes.
[ Laughter ]
By the way, I was thinking
about the Florida man.
-Yeah.
-And I remembered
that when they apprehended him,
they asked him, "What is this?"
And he said, "It's not mine."
[ Laughter ]
That's -- I don't know where the
story went after that, but...
[ Laughter ]
-I like that.
Yeah, that's true.
I mean, I feel like
that's every drug user's
first response to the cops,
is, "It's not mine."
[ Laughter ]
You -- there's a wonderful film
of the concert --
of the show, I should say --
on HBO Max
that Spike Lee directed.
Obviously, both of you have had
a long history in New York City.
When did you first meet?
-I think -- I'm not sure.
I think it might have been
when he did
"Do the Right Thing".
I remember going
to the premiere of that.
It was at the Ziegfeld.
It was like, "Wow.
This up-and-coming filmmaker
now has a film at the Ziegfeld."
And it's an amazing film,
if people haven't seen it.
I might have met him then
or some other time.
We started crossing paths.
We were both kind of coming up
at the same time.
-I think a lot of people sort of
romanticize 1970s New York,
which is when
you first came here.
But can you tell those of us
who are so upset
that we didn't get to live
in New York City then
at least one thing about it
that was worse?
[ Laughter ]
-I can tell you a lot of things
that are worse.
There was -- There was this law
that got passed in New York
sometime after that.
It was called
the pooper scooper law.
And for those people who don't
remember or weren't around,
they used to let dogs, well,
poop right on the sidewalk,
and the owner
would just walk on.
Like, uh, "Okay, that's --
You've done your business.
We're just moving on."
So if you were walking around
in New York,
you had to be looking down
all the time.
[ Laughter ]
-And inevitably, even though
you're trying
to be really careful,
you'd get some on you.
And you'd be there on the curb
or on the grass or somewhere,
trying to scrape it
off your shoes.
And that's not romantic.
There's nothing --
There's nothing good about that.
-No.
And then, if somebody walked by
while you were doing it,
you would say, "It's not mine,"
right?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
"I don't know
who put that there."
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, you also --
You have a book of your artwork
coming out soon.
This is a beautiful drawing.
Is this all art you did
during the pandemic,
or is this sort of predating?
-It's all during the pandemic.
As I think happened
to a lot of people
during the pandemic,
we were sometimes prohibited
from doing the things
that we normally do --
either going to work
or doing concerts
or whatever it might be.
And some of us took up cooking
or making bread,
and I started drawing.
And to some extent,
I think the drawings
kind of reflected the turmoil
that was going through --
going through not just my head,
but, I assume,
other people's heads, too.
-Well, it's really beautiful,
and I look forward
to seeing the book.
And I also look forward
to coming back
and seeing the show again.
Thank you so much
for being here, David.
-Thank you.
Good to see you again.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-David Byrne, everybody.
"American Utopia"
is running through April
at the St. James Theatre
and streaming on HBO Max.